being diagnosed efficiently saved my
life and I'm very open about that
because I think it's not something
that's talked about enough
autism first of all is very under
diagnosed especially in women because it
presents differently growing up I always
felt so different and I felt like I
didn't belong I didn't understand why I
was interested in different things or
when it came to social Communications I
there was this disconnect I didn't
understand why that was I felt very
isolated and separated and I wasn't
happy with who I was and I felt like I
had to change that
I
name is Olivia schlotfer I'm a senior
here at Yale College and I'm in the
Environmental Studies major
I am neurodiverse I am autistic and I
also have ADHD
[Music]
since being diagnosed and since being
here at Yale I've really come into my
own I accept who I am and I'm also a lot
easier on myself because I know my brain
is structured differently and that comes
with so many amazing things like I
Delight in such a very rich experience
in this world from a sensory perspective
I feel very connected to our natural
world that's why I'm in an Environmental
Studies major
um but it does also lead to some
difficulties
some of the things that I struggled
academically with in my first year
before getting diagnosed for example in
Long lectures during class I'd have a
lot of trouble sitting still especially
lecture formats I couldn't stay focused
for that amount of time if professors
were just writing things on the
chalkboard and there weren't slides for
me to consult I felt very lost I had a
lot of trouble being able to stay
focused and take notes even though I
wanted to learn there was some block
where I couldn't and that led to a lot
of anxiety because I felt like I didn't
know what was wrong I didn't know why I
wasn't able to do the things that I'd
been able to do in the past or I didn't
know why other people weren't struggling
with these things I'd go into exams and
it would take me a lot longer to
understand the questions and sometimes
I'd be so sure that I understood it and
yet I would interpret it differently and
I would misinterpret it and I wouldn't
understand why why that was and I also
wasn't able to finish exams because it
would take me longer to be able to sort
through the material or to understand
the question I would have to be you know
asking like raising my hand and I would
feel very awkward and uncomfortable
having to clarify things and then maybe
the professor wouldn't understand why I
didn't understand and I also didn't
understand it was a lot of uncertainty
that did create a lot of anxiety and
being able to get this diagnosis to
educate myself on okay this makes so
much sense I have all of these answers
now to why I feel this way and why I
experienced the world the way that I do
and it's so much knowledge that I have
now and has that's really allowed me to
accept myself and that's why now I'm so
open about things is because I want to
help other people and be a voice for
those who are struggling and don't know
why and haven't reached out for help yet
or are in the process and
art feeling like they love themselves
for who they are and I want to show that
it's okay to be different and being
neurodiverse is beautiful and it allows
us to bring a different perspective to
this world
[Music]
four students coming into Yale who are
Autistic or have a ADHD or another
disability I know that it can be
stressful and overwhelming and you don't
know where to start it's a new
environment you're coming into college
and it really does take you out of your
comfort zone
can be intimidating to approach
professors and be like actually I do
experience the world in a different way
I do learn differently but I would say
my experience with professors has been
overwhelmingly positive I would say just
at the start of the semester to open
that door for communication and to be
honest professors are people too they're
people who have their own world
experiences and can probably relate to a
lot of the struggles that you go with
you deal with even if it's not precisely
in the same way
please
[Music]
you have so many different resources to
help you hear whether that's your first
year counselor your Dean your head of
college
also mental health and counseling
student accessibility Services portable
Center there's so many different avenues
for you to get the help and the support
you need and I think there is still a
lot of stigma about you know getting
support getting whether that be tutoring
or therapy or academic accommodations
because it can make you feel less than
like oh I'm not good enough but that's
not how you should see it it should be
it's not that you're not good enough
it's that you learn in a different way
our academic system is set up for a
certain neurotype for people who learn a
certain way and academic accommodations
that helps to level the playing field
and to ensure fairness it's not giving
the leg up or it's not oh extra help no
it's allowing for there to be fairness
and ensuring there's an even playing
field so that everyone here at Yale can
Drive
[Music]
foreign thank you